Yay!
Excuse me, what the fuck?
Get him go!
He's prospecting!
Oh, me?
I know, I'm so good at not committing tax fraud.
Okay.
Guys, I'm watching this from my screen.
I'm from my OBS screen.
Which one's to confirm?
It's A.
Okay.
I pressed A.
Uh, and see how things unfold.
Let's aim for six or more residents to give your means.
of friends.
All right, we can do that.
Let me see if there is another alternative.
I think this is, like, the best one out of all of them,
honestly.
Big!
There you go.
Everyone else has such beautiful mees of me.
How did they all do it?
I'll never understand.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Doki.
My name is my name is my name.
Guys, I can't tell!
Duchess, having a nice evening.
Oh, that sounds good.
Okay, that's meant that text itself can, but the
pronunciation will need to be shortened.
Duchess 22-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W.
Let's throw that.
Duchess 22-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W.
I don't know, you can customize your island, too.
Like, you can, you can, like, terraform your island.
I don't know exactly.
Tell me about your life.
Living the dream.
I'm not related to other island.
Yay!
To Matachi life!
All right.
I have an idea.
My name is Doki.
All right.
I think...
Female?
Yay!
Reserved.
Aloof, logical, tenacious, cautious.
Speaks matter-factly.
Thoughtful, introspective.
Great at thinking things through and analyzing from every
angle.
That's right.
That's how the parasite was born.
They're starting to cheat each other.
See?
outgoing radian always on form their effortless style is my
but all and easily adapts to new situations optimistic and
passionate follows their instincts kevin from kevin from the
minions oh wait my name is kevin the minion my name is kevin
the minion
about a book straight talker puts a premium on results a
determined self-starter cuts their own path letting nothing
stand in their way quick oh my that's totally grew that's
definitely grew i win by doing nothing at all winning by
doing nothing i don't want to play during the night i want
to know what it's like when it's morning the game punishes
me by time travel No!
Oh!
Wait, it's sunset!
It's evening, sunset!
Alright, let's see.
I got a shop real quick before I...
Oh my god.
I have to buy this.
Alright, I don't even know how much money I have.
I don't need a no.
There's a t-shirt with cars, a crazy colored shirt.
Work from home.
Monkey.
I'm not broke yet.
We don't know.
If I always cover the money, we'll never know if I'm broke
or not.
Wait, it might get...
Oh.
It's time.
Get in the monkey costume.
Not sure that went well.
I think you look beautiful.
I have our fights.
But we always make up.
She hates it.
Monkey.
I don't know which donkey it is.
There's so many donkeys.
Alright, Gru.
going on good evening i don't really know kevin from the
minions movie come on what do you mean it's kevin the
minions yes oh my god absolutely absolutely oh yeah now i'm
kind of curious about oh my god yes yes it writes itself the
script i can see the script right now it's his only friend
too i see the script guys i also need to give you shoes
you're not wearing purple shoes you got a match i'm pretty
sure guru has black shoes there we go yeah now he looks
perfect yeah he likes it is everyone having a good time
Kevin.
Why is everybody outside?
Man, the day... Oh my god.
Come on, get out of here.
It's a beautiful day outside.
You know what?
Get in here.
You're gonna talk with Roo.
Actually... Whoa.
Whoa, actually, no.
He's...
I don't... He's taking pictures right now.
Yo, go meet Doki.
Oh, hey, Doki.
Kevin from the Minions movie.
Good evening.
Oh, that's it.
Oh, Gru doesn't like it.
He's like, what are you doing, Kevin?
He's like, what are you doing?
He's like, how dare you have a conversation without me?
Gru.
All right.
Atomy.
Let's see.
What dokey shall we make?
Let me pull up the dokeypedia.
You guys are going to be a little confused.
But it's all going to come together.
There we go.
And then trust the process, guys.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Oh, God.
Slow and steady.
Rome wasn't built in a day.
All right, time and time.
What's the speed run?
Apparently, they found the perfect Garfield voice.
So I'm going to try and recreate it.
Create it.
To get my name, Mr. Okay, one.
I think one.
Yeah, yeah, I hear it.
Okay, we're going to fix you.
It's outgoing.
I swear.
Oh, we got to make you lazy.
Where is the lazy?
go but finds a lot thought it's innocent okay this is as
good as we can get it's also orange this is actually as good
this is as good as we can get you have some smoked salmon
lobotomy done all right all right let's make you meet let's
make you meet some of the the new villagers nice we have
finally terraformed i want you to be friends with kevin the
minion Sure.
What should we talk about?
Jokey bird.
Other.
Oh, you should talk about others.
Oh, we all know that.
Nana.
Kevin, for the minutes of the week,
do you feel like talking about a banana?
Sure.
Would you say that a banana mix?
Do you think of the others?
Okay.
Um, uh, I guess they're both.
Yellow?
Oh, true, true.
That's true.
They're both yellow.
I think we're friends now.
Oh, my God.
Bonded by bananas.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
A palace house workshop has opened on not related to other
islands.
local palette house, Duchess 22, WW, WW, WW, WW, WW.
Okay, I touched.
Here in the palette, you can make different creations by
drawing pictures.
Now you're ready to make some food.
Why not make your first creation a piece of cake?
We started for you since it's your first one.
So all that's left is for you to give that cake its tasty
finishing touches.
If we're not, try using a stamp to the top of the screen.
Once you're done, press done.
Do I have to make a cake?
Or can I draw something else over it?
I'm so stupid.
I'm driving up.
This is the right one I want to use.
I'd rather erase this part.
All right.
Now it's perfect.
Is that the bite of 69?
There.
What does it taste like?
Salty type.
I would say it's a pretty meanie.
Oh, no.
It's a meanie.
dish temperature oh definitely room temperature medium oh
yeah oh large no it has to be a large would you like a bite
of 67 oh i just feel one of those gonna turn in chicken oh
she liked it oh she liked it the bite of 67
I'm gonna do clothes.
Maybe I'll draw some clothes for my dokees.
Oh my god, wait, is that Garfield modeling?
Wait, that looks sick on him!
Wait a minute!
I think it's time to make a new dokee.
This dokee!
So beautiful.
Oh my gosh, dokee.
You're so beautiful.
Yeah, I think it's good.
I know what to make now.
Oh,
that's too...
Oh, it's too high.
It's okay.
I can fix that.
This is the hardest part, guys.
This truly is the hardest part.
And then...
I don't know if I can draw the answer.
Back, um...
You know, we tried.
I'm pretty sure I got the raw skin tone.
Something on your mind.
It's closing I need to like see her color Before it's fine
It's good enough I mean if you look from here it looks the
same If you look from here it works I guess Oh what are you
thinking
You should definitely be friends with Doki What should we
talk about What should we talk about Being so sexy.
Got it.
I'll go talk to her about being so sexy.
Good evening, don't you?
Do you feel like talking about?
Being so sexy.
Sure, but tell me.
Groove from Despicable Me movie How good are you at being so
sexy?
It works so good But I do think you'll find anyone on call
Not related to other islands He's better at being so sexy
Oh, she's so impressed I respect folks who are good at being
so sexy Yeah!
It works so good!
It works a bit!
Apparently you guys said we can create a...
We can create a pet now.
It's good enough.
It's close enough.
It's Amagos.
Look at him.
You gave her an Amagus.
Hey, take it out.
Look at him, go.
Look at him, look.
Oh my god, look at him, go.
He's prospecting.
Let's bring Doki.
Doki, stop dancing.
You gotta help Doki.
So kind of big.
But she just wants to dance.
I want to be friends with Doki.
Which one?
Okay.
Oh, that Doki.
We should talk about being so sexy.
What did you have in mind?
An activity.
Paying our taxes.
All right.
Not committing tax fraud, guys.
Got it.
I'll go talk to her about not committing tax fraud.
They're always watching guys.
They're always watching Good evening doki Hey doki.
Do you feel like talking about?
Not committing tax fraud.
Okay, but check this out Visualize not committing tax fraud.
Good.
Do you want to tell me?
Do you visualize it?
I know it's so hard.
It's so hard to do Oh me.
I know I'm so good at not committing tax fraud I'm gonna
pencil you in for not submitting tax fraud ASAP.
I'm visualizing it.
Oh my god, I'm thinking about it.
I'm thinking about keeping all my receipts.
I'm thinking about talking to my tax guy, my accountant, and
then making sure I pay everything on time.
Oh, I'm thinking it's so hard right now.
Oh, hey, Guru.
Oh, God, who said, I'd love to play around the 14th game.
That made them too accurate.
Oh, kimchi.
The bite of 67?
Is that...
Where is the bite?
Hmm.
So what's missing from here?
Three.
Two.
Oh, tomato juice.
What's missing is...
Oh, you're right.
the restaurant oh talk to them interact with them dokey oh
you don't want to talk to dokey but you want to talk to
kevin oh my oh it's because they're just acquaintances oh oh
my god oh my god Groo's pose.
Oh my god.
Doki's posing for Groo.
It's a shoot.
Mono shoot.
Oh, it's beautiful.
That's right.
To the left now.
This way.
Look at me.
Oh, fabulous.
Donkey.
Fabulous.
I have a little photo shoot there for only Doki's.
Follows their instincts.
Radiant always on for him.
Their effortless style is my ball.
Easily adapts to a new situation.
Oh, we're gonna try bowling.
Let's do bowling.
Oh my god, we have enough villagers for bowling, guys.
Yay!
Excuse me, what the fuck?
I got a split.
If I hit here, it's gonna, like, hit Kevin.
No!
It didn't hit Kevin!
Okay, I fucked up.
Just went in the middle.
Oh my god.
We got a spare.
too bad oh okay i think we're ready for a new resident guys
i think we're ready i know exactly what we're gonna get
welcome aloof logical tenacious cautious speaks matter of
faculty yeah you guys are mid imagine if inspired happiest
when creating something finds beauty in everyone and
everything welcome
Hey, Dragoons.
I'm Doki.
Now you're no sexy dude.
Wait, no!
She had to do that.
No.
Look at that.
You're friends now.
Guys, look at that.
Hey, Doki.
Are you okay?
she's practicing really
that's me disassociating oh my god she's getting ready she's
practicing for asking her up oh wait she got friend zone in
her own reenactment that's pretty sad dokey
Hold up.
Did I just get rejected during my own practice run?
She's the Lulu right now.
Alright, we'll finally do it, guys.
I'm just gonna use a template.
Whoops.
You know what that works.
There we go.
I think that's perfect.
Dad.
Here's dad.
Look at him, he's so lagged.
It's probably a dog.
Oh, oh, is she bringing it home?
Wait, I think she might bring it home.
Oh, oh.
Oh, there he is!
Look at him go.
Oh my god, Tokyo's taking time.
You're on a walk right now!
Oh my god, you're so right.
Practically looks like the same one.
Well, everybody said, hey, how are you?
Where's your dad?
All right.
Time to meet your dad.
I'm Doki.
Hey, Doki.
Yay!
You're not queen to sister with your dad.
Isn't that great?
Oh yeah, it is scary.
Streaming is scary.
Seems like mine it.
All right, we're going to call it here.
I think more stuff will unlock if I have more mees.
But I'm not, I don't know what, I don't want to make another
me right now.
They take so much work.
I don't really feel like making another me at the moment.
That was fun.
Another day.
Another drama filled day on Doki Island.